welcome
everyone to the data science hangout
welcome back to
all the familiar faces i think most
everybody's been on here at least once
but also welcome to those joining for
the first time
thank you rob for covering for me last
week while i was out on
vacation yeah but for today's
episode um or just to kind of
level set on the data science hangout as
well for for people who are new to this
these discussions on data science
leadership in the enterprise range from
very human oriented topics to a little
bit of technical talk
but really focusing on questions that
are most important to you
all so there's no agenda please join in
live or put any questions that you have
in the chat
with that said i'd like to just jump in
here and enjoy introduce
tori oblak enterprise data and analytics
officer
at waffed bank tori is
extremely passionate about training and
building community so i'm super excited
to talk a bit more about that today too
tori would you be able to kick things
off by introducing yourself and
maybe sharing a bit about the work you
do on your team
sure um so for backgrounds
i have degrees in econ and math i've
been doing data science professionally
for about 20 years
in health care and in banking
i'm currently working at waffed bank
where i'm actually starting the data
science program there
so awesome
um so i know we have these kind of
standard questions that we kick things
off with until people start
jumping in with questions um so one that
i'd love to ask you is
what are you really excited about right
now with data science
um this isn't totally
new new but i'm really when i first
started
i was in sas and that's not very
accessible
so over the years it's been fun to see
the accessibility not just of tools but
really of data science being able to
be shared with people i'm now having
conversations with people where
they're starting to want to learn and
you couldn't like take sas to your house
and learn it
but right now currently at work one of
the things i'm instituting is having
r as a standard so anybody in the
company that actually wants to do it
can start learning i'm not quite there
but we're close that's something i'm
super interested in because a lot of
people will
ask me about how they start their own
internal
usar group or build their data science
community
and i'm curious what is starting to or
what has worked well for you or what are
you doing to try and start to build this
um what i found the most useful is
it's really time expensive but starting
with a few
key people in areas that want to learn
something
working with them one-on-one on
something very
if i can fix or help them fix help them
figure out how to fix their problem so
it has to be
something that affects them otherwise it
goes away they forget what they've
learned
starting that community where it's
one-on-one hands-on training
like what what are the issues okay how
do you think you should go about it
if there when you can find those key
people that are excited
they will actually start learning and
they become these internal
wow this is really exciting and it's
more credible
to hear from somebody that is not a data
scientist or super programmer that's
scarier
that you can do it so i found that is
really helpful to have like resident
whether they are excel users or whatever
type of more beginner analysts to help
internally a community data science
community is a little different
um i can talk about that too because i
think that's fun
so i don't know uh if people are more in
companies where you have a central data
science or
you're more distributed
what do people live in i don't know
yeah feel free to go quiet feel free to
weigh in in the chat or
or speak live too um but i know what
i've heard from some people
um lately is like how do we actually
find those people that would want to
learn or like the super
excel power users that could maybe
benefit from
using a tool like r or python because i
think
like you said they may not have that
data science title
so how do you go about like finding all
of those people
so one thing um i've found very helpful
is just for data science in general to
be
successful is to partner with the
business
and generally your business users are
not
programmers
but it a lot of that communication where
okay we have
an objective that we're trying to meet
through those discussions generally
you'll find small bits of oh well
how are you going about that maybe we
can tackle that in a different way
so it turns into a lot of small side
projects but it says
those relationships that you're making
for the bigger data science issues that
you find
the small guys that need help
i'd love to chime in here i am at my
company
what i found to be very helpful is
leading little learning cohorts
and i really focus on eda because
our our studio is awesome
pro-exploratory data analysis
so i can create these little cohorts
some business analysts in there who work
in let's say inventory management or
transportation
pair them up with people working right
who would you say are more technical
data analysis um roles
and if you can get them learning
together on a cadence right they form
the relationships
they understand each other's problems
and they learn r
at the same time and then once you write
any excel user who discovers r
it's unlikely that they're going to say
wait i'm going to only use
excel from now on so yeah
that's great and frank if you feel
comfortable doing so be great to
introduce
yourself as well to the group uh yeah
i'd love to
i'm really glad to be here this is my my
first session
um i work at target i live out in
minnesota
uh my whole life i've been on the coast
either up in uh
new york boston new jersey or in san
francisco
for the past three years i came to work
with target uh in there
so i came to build let's say a hybrid
business intelligence team so when i
came here we weren't necessarily calling
ourselves
business intelligence or analytics or
any of that we called ourselves
transportation performance
to distinguish ourselves and really it's
a i built teams of
um pretty good uh python and our users
tell any anyone who didn't know that
right and i taught them r first because
i think r is a great introduction
and then if they want to do more machine
learning nlp stuff they get into python
but for the past three years i've been
building teams that really sit in the
middle of
the business and then being able to do
data analysis at a pretty rapid rate
um i lead a team now that i call
decision intelligence
it's a little bit of a branding strategy
on my part but i need my stakeholders to
be
thinking about the decisions so when
they say hey what do you do what is your
team doing
i say well we start with the decisions
you're making and the actions you're
taking and then we
can find the analytics to support that
so that's what i do now i lead a team
mostly support transportation within the
supply chain of target
um but i'd say my passion in target is
teaching people especially except like
heavy excel users
how to get to the the next step of what
i call higher powered
um data analytics
awesome thanks for joining frank thanks
for inviting me
yeah frank you brought up a really good
point something i found
very useful when you start having a
community even if it's just a data
scientist and you don't know who
is interested in learning r or even what
data science is is
creating more of a it has to be organic
or it doesn't really work
but having those more of like lunch and
learns where it's hey
invite your friends because i think
people forget
how powerful their networks are and like
you invite this friend who has another
friend
and um so i'm new to this position these
are
i i'm still building that internal
community
from where i came from it was
interesting because we had a few data
scientist
groups throughout the bank and
over just a few weeks where people come
and say hey this is the cool thing i'm
learning
we started getting in compliance humans
which do not speak
computer so it was exciting where
the understanding of even what is what
is possible out there
really started to spread organically
with people you wouldn't even expect
so that was that was awesome so don't
forget your friends
and your friends friends they are it is
a very powerful and good way to create
that organic
growth of information and knowledge
and for the the lunch and learns that
you do is that something that's
weekly or monthly so we started out
um i think quarterly but then people
were really interested and they wanted
to actually show oh
i'm actually working on this thing and
it it relates to this other person's
thing so
we started doing it not quite every
other week that's a lot i think we're
doing it about every three weeks
okay so yeah that consistency it
probably really helps too
yeah it was interesting too and
something that
started to happen it started out more
data science heavy but
what i thought was useful is so a lot of
data scientists
you know we love to talk about the nerdy
geeky stuff
and it turned into not
just algorithms but more context where
people are getting a good
audience of practicing for your who you
really need to be talking to to get
buy-in like your executives they're not
going to
totally care about your algorithms
unfortunately
understanding how to speak to that
broader audience it became fun for
people though because it was
hey this is this neat thing that i'm
doing why i'm doing it and how it works
let me explain it in layman's terms
then um what was also nice is people
from other parts of the bank that
weren't
in data science with the the girl that
was running up
ads she had no background in it so she
explained
how her job worked what it worked like
how she
basically how optimization of google
works and she started working with one
of the data scientists to make it better
which i don't think would have happened
without that internal community which is
awesome
so that is that's great
i don't want to leave this topic yet if
that's okay with
with everyone because i see there's a
lot of great comments in the
the chat window too and i was wondering
if um
maybe sep if you wanted to weigh in with
with your experience here too
yeah sure um hi everybody my name is
seth i'm sure we'll get to know each
other more over the
over the weeks i find this a very
interesting uh
forum just to kind of see how people in
different industries even um are
are impacting their their organizations
um
i think for me uh being in kind of
healthcare and healthcare tangent kind
of organizations which
in general stereotypically are not very
technical forward sometimes i find
uh explaining a lot of or showing a lot
of like the art of the possibility to be
kind of
a fun uh a fun exercise um
and i see rick's comment like and i
totally agree i
i don't like to just do necessarily
flashy but just to kind of
to say hey look there's there's some
efficiency gains that could be that
could be made
if we kind of do things this way so
that's kind of just the comment i wanted
to kind of make there
yeah i think too the flashy
even the simple what but generally we
think is
really simple most people don't realize
how easy it is to get a data set
and play with it and make it easy
like the the horrible manual processes
that people go through like
none of us would do that anymore but
it's everywhere
and like fixing that they go into excel
and manually changing things every
single month
like just revealing that that is not
something you have to do ever again
it's the funny funny example that i
always give is
because my name is seth if you put sep
in excel it renders to september
um and uh and i find it annoying and it
and it's another reason i just hate
excel
um but uh but i always kind of show that
example is that if you're gonna be
dealing with names
and you get a name like mine and excel
renders it to september and then you go
export that
and someone's dealing with it it ends up
being causing these kind of
issues because it's trying to make it
easy for you but i use that example all
the time it's a pretty funny one
eric i see you had a question around
fostering that internal community
do you want to ask that one live sure um
so great to be here
for those who don't know my name's eric
i'm in life sciences industry
and quite a passionate r user in my
various endeavors um
but my questions have been loaded i
don't know if others
or others have experience with this but
i read an internal r form at my company
and it's
very well attended everybody seems to
enjoy it
and i try my best to let others feel
like
be comfortable sharing the cool things
they're doing with our because we know
ours being more prevalent in our company
and across life sciences in general
but i don't know if it's just me i just
get a heart i have a hard time getting
others to lead topics it tends to fall
on me or some of the other what i'll
call the uh
established power users if you will
so i don't know if you had advice on
fostering that
engagement of everybody feeling
being comfortable to kind of share their
their wins with our you know cool things
they're doing even if they just have
questions
it's a bit loaded i don't know if you
had any advice on making people feel
comfortable to
present their work in a forum like that
it's hard
yes it's really hard found out the hard
way
i've found um i've had to spend a lot of
time one-on-one with the person then
just be like
you know we're planning to present this
would you be part of that if you need
any help prepping i would love that but
it'd be
so great to debut your work because
xyz it's relevant in this way which
people haven't seen or they could relate
to you
but it it's time expensive training and
and getting people on board anyway is
super time expensive
unless somebody's found a magic pill
i've been looking for a long time i have
not found it yet um the training piece
is
even harder than just the community
piece of it in my
humble opinion um i do have some people
helping me with the forum i lead which
is very helpful we try to reach out to
certain people but
yeah i just was hoping i could get more
kind of people coming to us and saying
hey you know i had this great idea or
you know i'm
i just don't get that as much and i'm
trying to figure out ways of
incentivizing that a bit but i'll i'll
keep searching if you want the only
um thing that i've found is helpful is i
haven't
like what i've done so far hasn't been
restricted to a specific topic
at all so you're not required to do
r or something amazing it's more of
we just want to share something
interesting with each other that might
benefit
that that's helpful because it's less
stress
that's great points yeah thank you
something that's
helped me with the boston user group
is if i can't find a speaker sometimes
i'll make it a series of lightning talks
and so have very short presentations
that people will give and
people seem to feel a lot more
comfortable with that especially if it's
their first one
and i think that's a much easier ask to
someone than
saying like lead this 45 minute session
yeah that's a great point i'll keep that
in mind thank you
hi my name is edgar i work with daimler
trucks i'm
happy to be here enjoy the forum too um
i was going to share eric what we've
done
in our company um is
kind of phrase it as what gap have you
mastered lately
right what what happened and then that
gets people talking from a
i learned standpoint versus i don't know
how to do this standpoint
uh that's that's one approach and then
the other approach is we just rotate who
facilitates the meeting and that tends
to take
different interests sometimes people
have a very concise
problem they want to fix or or a way to
go about something that's not available
whether it is
it is not permitting it or the software
doesn't do it
and then it becomes that kind of
self-guided type of conversation but
definitely
something along the lines of what gap
have you mastered lately
oh that's cool yeah thank you for
sharing that here yeah happy to do so
maybe i can uh chime in on the um how to
get people to show their their stuff for
eric
so i'm rick i also work in the life
sciences and i work a lot with
researchers that
are doing and i do a lot of training in
r like 90 of my work is doing training
and teaching and mentoring
and all variety of different capacities
and one thing that i've
done a lot is to uh get them more
be more comfortable discussing and
showing their work because a lot of
things that a lot of there's a lot of
hurdles
for new starters in any topic to get
over
is that it's not perfect and it's not
the right way so they don't they're a
little bit embarrassed to show their
their
their stuff um so to help them get over
that what i'll do is um
i've done i've done this in person and
now it's easier that now i do things all
online
is that i get them to share their screen
or i i get them to explain what they're
doing so if i if i give them an exercise
and um i would just ask them like how
they solved exercise and
i don't maybe something that a lot of
pedagogical people disagree with i i
don't give them
really simple questions that have a
really nice easy clear answer
i give them an example that has the
answer and i say okay do it
and it's amazing how many times people
just don't do exactly what's in the
example so they start trying all kinds
of weird and wacky things i'm like okay
fine just do it
i don't say go and look at that example
and do it so they start doing weird
things
and i say okay how did you do this and
then they describe it to me and then
i'll type it out or
i'll get them to charge their screen if
i can't uh if i if it's possible
and then other people see what they're
doing um so that also kind of helps
helps them work and then what i did in
the
in the workshops i would usually do with
researchers is they would have time
to do their own analysis and at the end
of the workshop i would be looking at
what they're doing
and if i saw somebody that had like a
really really cool example really made
some nice progress
i would say hey do you want to take five
minutes and show everybody the stuff i
did in class and then i would help them
and i would you can be like
co-presenters
and uh we would present it together and
then i would say oh look what this
person did over here and then
i could go in the computer i can type
and things like that and then i was kind
of
their co-pilot in doing that so that
seemed to help them a lot and then
they would be a little bit less um less
uh
self-conscious about it and then the
third thing that i do is um
i would have them they would they would
just ask me questions like i would go
around and say okay like what is your
project what are you working on
and then they would say things like is
it is it possible to read in
like several files and i'm like yeah
it's not a problem you've been doing
thousands of files no problem and
they're like wow okay like like how and
then
and then uh i would say okay well you
know let's try and figure it out and
then i'm presented to the class
and then that would give me a chance to
explain deeper all the problems with
that without topic and things you need
to watch out for
and then they would be very much engaged
because they're like oh i really see
usefulness of this activity inside
so all those things i think help to have
them get them be a little bit easier to
present
oh it's very nice rick lots of good
nuggets there um we definitely have
tried like having like
certain themes throughout the year of
like maybe we're going to talk more
about
our markdown or we're going to talk more
about interacting with databases and
stuff like that but i kind of see your
point if you get them actively working
on something then
don't hold their hand but let them be a
little more innovative and a little more
creative then you can
clean some nuggets from that too so yeah
that's very cool
thank you eric i feel like that kind of
leads into one of the questions that
hugh
asked as well around
like helping new r users power through
the initial learning curve
hugh do you want to provide any more
context on
that question sure my name's hugh welch
this is my third time on these calls and
my first time
interacting i'm a management analyst
with veteran health administration
i've been using r for the last couple
years to build
informatics products and we've been
getting a lot of interest in those
and people around different facilities
wanting to
kind of replicate some of that like
that's cool how do i get into r
um and i kind of feel like you know it's
uh okay well
here's two books uh a couple data camp
courses
uh vignettes on all the tidy verse
packages read through these and and then
we can uh
you know we can start talking about what
to do um
so it's been kind of difficult getting
people who uh
some of whom have some programming
background maybe you know they've done
some visual basic or they've done
familiar with sql or familiar with some
stuff but a lot of them
are just power excel users and kind of
getting them through that
mental shift into there's a different
way of thinking about this
um has been been an area that's been
pretty difficult
um i've noticed remote is harder for me
to get people
into it because i used to just go to
somebody's desk and sit down next to
them and talk through
even getting it are on your computer
setting it up and doing
simple things initially because then the
person is set up they know these
simple things they can get into but
without the
what i've now started doing is doing a
lot of screen sharing
i can't remember who brought that up but
screen sharing where you can interact
at least if you can't type on each
other's you can
either have the person watch you for a
while and then have them
do something so that after you hang up
they can at least refer back to what you
went over
but if i don't do that if i'm just like
hey go watch this tutorial it doesn't go
anywhere
i've noticed like there has to be some
initial
i can do this on my own when somebody's
not holding my hand
and then people are comfortable going to
different resources
it has to be absolutely applicable to
their daily life or they're not going to
do it
and definitely finding that practical
application is
uh sometimes challenging especially with
new people who want to do something
really complicated
like let's start with let's start with
this very simple problem
and get you some you know do some eda on
it do some
basic aggregation pull in some files you
know we're not gonna
we're not gonna build a model like in
the first 10 minutes that tells you what
you need to know
yeah but thank you i was thinking
actually about putting together
maybe some company our markdowns with
some very simple applicable to broad
um areas so you know we're pulling in
data
well it's generally excel so make that
simple for them to swap out what data
and we want to graph it make it very
simple just so they have little snippets
of code that
it's super simple if you've played an r
but if when you're new you're like
what is gg printing what are my inputs
and it's overwhelming so people just
stop
so just making it okay i'm gonna make
you feel powerful and make something
beautiful from a very simple script that
you can run on your own
i should probably actually do that not
think about it
yeah and you know i just finished a
master's in analytics and and some of
the professors had great primers on
where to start
because the backgrounds vary so
establishing
difference between r and r studio and
our studio libraries and
how powerful our studio is i mean you
immediately fall in love with it
but the cool thing is you know the
primer includes things to
um to the effect of create a folder put
this file in excel in it
you'll read it with this script but then
go open it and check out what you did
because you're going to edit the
r studio and and and that just not only
builds kind of the
mental model of how things work but also
the trust on your new interface
so that that really worked well for us
well for me as a student that is
it's funny trying to like imagine if we
were all in person right now and
so i take the signal of unmuting as
thinking maybe somebody's
about to speak so i was wondering if
frank if you wanted to
add anything to yeah uh following off
with what tori was saying i
i feel as though i've had good success
writing starter scripts for people
um just taking updates so we are lucky
at target to have
both an awesome package called bullseye
connect
written by this guy alex meyer that
connects to all our databases
so right you install the package and
then you get it
you connect it to any database basically
in the company
so that's one and then the second thing
that's been huge is we have um
hosted our studio and hosted jupyter
notebooks so
all you do is go to a link and then say
like start a new instance of varsity
right just
like if you were doing it on kaggle but
we have it for target so you're on our
vpn and
um you can access the data so that has
been huge
and it makes it very easy for me if
someone is interested in r then say
hey what data do you use most often okay
let's find your
your data source and then basically just
build a script that's
what 20 30 lines of code and go through
read in the data
maybe do a tiny bit of cleaning
aggregate it
build a cool visualization with plotly
and write immediately they're like oh
this is cool and then you can change
one or two fields and say like you have
an awesome facet plot here
change one field and now you have
something completely different and
you're seeing your data in a way that
you've never seen it before
um you can get people to that really
fast
uh and some people will stick with it
some people be like this
is great i'm gonna use this insight and
i'm never coming back to this again
some people are going to go with it but
then right
the the cost of doing that and building
those starter scripts individually
is really low because we have the right
tools um so you can find out who is
actually like the level of engagement
for different users
it doesn't doesn't really matter the the
portion of them that fall off versus the
portion that adopts it
because the portion that adopts it will
then i think go on to become
evangelizers don't discount those
oh sorry don't just count the people
that don't um
use it though because at least they know
what's possible and those people
can become very good evangelizers like
knowing that possible
yeah they're like oh wait i know if you
talk to so-and-so
you can actually solve this problem
there that is a big cohort because
a lot of people are not gonna they're
not gonna keep going
it's just how it is they're still it's
still not a waste your time so don't
don't get too discouraged sorry hugh i
interrupted you
no you're good i was just going to say
thank you to frank i really like that
idea of uh
doing some of the grunt work for them to
make it really easy to
to grab some stuff and get some
immediate results
so that they can kind of engage quickly
and then if they're interested
uh figure out how it actually works so
they can do it themselves and break it
apart and
you know make it and they will there'll
be plenty of those people
right that run it and think this is
amazing and yeah then they start doing
it every day
yeah because it's some of that you know
set up stuff scares a lot of people away
because they see oh
code and connections and i don't know
what this means i'm just gonna you know
i'm gonna move on
at the what was that called bullseye
connect that's actually the first
package i wrote here
because i was like things get people get
stuck on connecting to the data and you
can't do anything without that
connection so
others don't have that internal thing
that i think is absolutely
key you can't get to the data they're
kind of
they're kind of stuck and they're not
not going to get out of excel because
they don't have access to anything else
that's a great point oh it sounded like
someone was about to say something
if i if i can jump jump in i uh
completely agree with the uh the starter
script uh package
or the idea of having the scar scripts
um and i think one one thing that i
add on top of that is that um
is helping them to a lot of the really
like people that never did anything
programmatic or
command line tools or any any typing in
the terminal or anything
they just don't get the they don't have
the mental model somebody mentioned this
the mental models i think that's really
important um not just into the
algorithms but also like
how this thing fits together right so
they don't appreciate that
um self-referential functions that
change the input that you can't run them
twice
right like if i do a log 10 of a
variable i can't run that
function again because i'm going to get
error messages and then they freak out
it's like well why did i get a message
like well because you did the log 10 to
a log 10 and
like that they don't they don't get that
they don't see why that's a great thing
they don't see that they can replace a
variable and they don't get a warning
message that they've replaced it
so what i do is um i think one one nice
thing is to try and help them
to build up the whole workflow they're
not just so they put the whole workflow
from top to bottom so
if you have a a solution in excel that
they've already done
and this comes back to the other idea
right like how do you make it relevant
for them
um that script is going to be based on
something that's really involved in the
project that they're working on or some
idea
and you have this the solution in excel
and the one i like to do is qpcr
because scientists love this technique
and there's no clear standardized way
to analyze the results because every
different system is complete mass
and everybody's spending a lot of time
doing their analysis on qpcr so they
have their
terrible solution in excel and spss and
graphite prism and things like this and
then i say okay so let's write basically
just like pseudocode
like what do we need to do we need to
calculate this we need to calculate this
and we need to calculate this and we can
make this plot
and then they have a hard time sometimes
telling me like what they want to do
then it's communications issues and i
get to talk to them about
how they need to describe what they're
talking about and how when they say
something like i need to take the mean
of the weight
so and then they'll type the mean of um
i want i want the mean of each group
something like that right so i'll say i
take the mean and then inside the
brackets they'll put the grouping
variable
and i'm like like colloquially when we
say take the mean of each group
we know we mean we mean to say take the
weight according to each of the group
variables
but that's not how we have to type it so
they type literally how they think and
then all these kind of discussions help
them to kind of see in their head
this conversion from what they do in
excel into into r so then we build like
the pseudocode
piece by piece by piece and then they
can basically fill in the blanks of all
the commands and they can see all the
different steps
and then in doing that i also tell them
um if you can't get
one part don't worry about it because
the analysis part here
is separate from the visualization part
and it's separate from this part down
here so if you if you get stuck on that
part just do what you can then just
leave it and then go to the
visualization and if you if you get
stuck there
then go back to the analysis and then go
to this part here so you don't have to
do
one piece of to get the next part and
you can kind of go back and see i
haven't
know the general idea that i can then
pull it out um in the end
i think this kind of thing so thank you
rick
i i see steven asked a question that
kind of revolves around this
conversation as well
um stephen would you want to introduce
yourself and ask that question
yeah um absolutely this is the first
hangout i've joined so this is kind of
cool
and i i started in sas and i moved to r
and i learned that it is not as simple
as like oh just check out this vignette
and go do that
and i want i really resonate with what
he was saying he's like
uh go take this specialization corsair
and come back and we'll talk
like six months later or something i'm
trying to find the right level of data
literacy to build
in our company i'm comfortable with r in
our markdown
i have a senior statistician who is but
for those junior members
i want to enable them to get out of
excel i even want to enable them to just
do simple things like pivot table so i'm
trying to figure out like does it make
sense to
really invest in having them learn r
over six months to a year or you know
we're talking we talked about about
these dashboards and interactive things
there's middle grounds i i think to take
um
i guess my comment or maybe i'm curious
what you guys have done in finding like
which people are are the right ones to
just make them like pivot table masters
versus those who should really be
spending time to learn are and
and know how to code things ground up
really depends on the person's interest
right
and i've noticed some people just are
not
interested at all they see
that excel is their thing and so um
there are a couple people i've been
working with lately that
fall into this category and so i have
gone through
excel with them to try to at least make
it a little more efficient
but it still wasn't doing what we were
doing so on the side
i did something in r for them and have
like this little dashboard
that they can go interact with the data
and one of the guys is like
oh this is way better you know
i actually i i can actually learn some
things and and
it was interesting after spending a
couple months with him in
excel and then just being like can you
play with this because i can't get it to
work exactly
in excel the way i want does this work
for you and he
at that point after we we've struggled
together forever
he's like wow okay maybe i will try
so it seems really person to person an
interest level
i don't know like you mentioned learning
tableau
power bi um
a lot of particularly management doesn't
seem to well actually a lot of people
don't understand the difference between
why you'd want a full-blown
programming language versus say a power
bi or tableau
and if the data is great
sure they can they can use power bi but
if it's not good they're going to
struggle to death if they want to do
anything that's not out of the box
i i went down that path i don't know
maybe five years ago and i was like nope
i am not going to train people on
tableau and power bi it's it's too much
to take on
in addition plus i think most of the
problems have to do
they run into data issues
anybody else have thoughts
well i was going to say um do one of
these
and when i when i started introducing
art to a lot of the
management at target and clutching they
were like what do you mean it's free
like it's open source just use it
um but uh going back to
excel in particular i um
even my team of analysts i encourage
them build toy models in excel
right if you can think through the idea
in excel you're going to be able to
easily explain it to people
so i'm a huge proponent of starting that
way
for both business analysts operators
data analysts
because it's so fast and if you can
build a toy model in excel
then you can say okay we want to do even
quicker or we want to do this at a
higher
a higher scale then you move over to the
r world
really quick example again i work in
supply chain
we are trying to figure out how do
trucks move around our yards and when
are they going to get too full
i built the first thing in excel because
it was super easy to explain to
everybody how i was thinking about it
the information that i didn't have
and once everyone said yeah it looks
like it gets pretty close to the answer
we're looking for it helps us make
decisions
and i said okay great this is for 1bc i
need to do it for 25
not creating 25 spreadsheets right then
i just put the the logic in r and i was
able to do it
right pretty pretty darn quickly for all
of our distribution centers
yeah i think people knock excel it's a
it is a great prototyping tool and it
allows for that communication with the
business where they're not
a lot of people aren't going to learn
your code but they will
go through an excel workbook so like it
is a useful tool
that um helps with communication and
building that relationship with the
business
i know we don't want to use it but what
i'll meet them where they are
yeah exactly
so i love this i was just going to be
quiet for the rest of the time but i've
actually been down this exact road with
tableau and power bi
for the last few years um vha had a
enterprise contract with tableau a few
years ago and we
developed uh significantly there
thinking that was going to be the future
and then two years ago uh they decided
they're going to cut the contract
and go to all microsoft and said we're
going to migrate to power bi
like that's it's not a migration if i
can't take my work with me
and so we found that uh
we were suddenly tasked with
redeveloping
so many things that we'd built over the
last several years we started looking
around to see
what were some other options and that's
why we we started to go down the r path
the ability to be platform agnostic from
my perspective
over the last couple years has been
invaluable to know that
there's talk of contract shifts again
here coming for the federal government
and knowing that
no matter what happens uh i can take my
work with me and i don't have to keep
rebuilding things
and i can uh give somebody to the code
to reproduce and repeat it
without having to explain all the data
transformations
uh and how the the calculations interact
uh
has been just invaluable so
a good point that's a that's another
thing i keep evangelizing specifically
too
a lot of banking um
heavily relies on vendors and often
um i know other industries do too but it
feels worse in banking than it even was
in healthcare
where proprietary
software it comes with support and like
you're
but you're putting yourself in vendor
lock-in and you end up having to try to
figure out what's going on and you have
no idea
so i agree with you 100 here like
to be technology agnostic
is is what you want
you and tory with any of both the
industries that you work in i
i'd love to cover david's question
really around compliance
david would you be able to introduce
yourself and and your role and ask that
question
yeah sure i'll be happy to so um my name
is david dreyer i'm a technical expert
at
syngenta crop protection um so yeah we
work in a pretty regulated environment
um in the pesticide industry and as a
result you know we have compliance with
what are called good laboratory
standards so we have to
you know kind of understand that the
data from you know cradle to decision
essentially and you know with a lot of
these guideline
studies they rely on kind of black box
methods for
data analysis and system statistics but
you know
there's a lot of opportunity here to
potentially use some of the you know
open source
you know software to you know improve
essentially the analysis transparency
etc
of our studies and so i'm just curious i
mean obviously you work in a very
different
industry but um still compliance is is
common
i'm kind of interested in how you manage
those relationships and
you could tell us a little bit more
about that
so um in my experience if i cannot
explain my models compliance isn't going
to go for it unless it's from
like marketing you have a lot more
leeway and
and then i'm not sure people call what
they're doing is modeling
but within modeling and particularly in
banking if you do not have good
explainability at least none of my
compliance
people or auditors are okay with it
so i'm sorry i wish i had a better
answer here do you
is it huge i was gonna say uh working in
healthcare
um you're right explainability uh the
ability to
kind of backtrace your whatever you've
done and show your work has
is a requirement i mean there's uh
there's
regulations out there that you have to
be able to show somebody
uh you know why the algorithm picked
whatever it picked for them
my use here has been pretty niche it's
mostly operations
and it's not very widespread which is
kind of why i asked about the you know
getting new users on board because
they're starting to
see that you know the value in it but we
have to be incredibly careful that
everything we do is approved by our it
uh and that we're incredibly uh careful
with what we
uh what we do with our data because it's
not our data um so
we are very thoughtful with every step
step of the process to make sure that
we're in compliance with all the rules
and regulations and
uh bureaucracy but um most of what we do
is we're not building black box models
that
you know i can't tell you why this
neural network's let's spit out this
answer
um what i'm more trying to do is tell
you how many patients are going to be
here tomorrow
and where are they going to be and
what's their cancer likely cancellation
rate so you can
you know maybe over book or things like
that
echoing david's question too it'd be
great to also hear
how you build confidence in the tools as
well especially in these regulated
environments
where you need everything from document
document verification of infrastructure
to change controls validation and a
quality system
um that has been pretty good actually
because
excel what everybody has been doing for
years
it is not easy to tell when people make
a change or why they did the change
and so showing change control and how
you can revert in the past and exactly
what the change was why when
it makes people go oh yeah why haven't
we always done that
so there's there's something i'm working
on right now specifically because
the auditability wasn't in the process
they're like we actually need to
understand what's happening when i was
like oh
well we gotta change out of excel guys
and let me show you why and they're like
oh
yes this is exactly what we need and it
made compliance super duper happy
um with your relationship with
compliance
so i have a lot of talks regularly with
compliance people so
like i i've built some good
relationships so we have open
conversations where we're actually
teaching each other some things we can
have more common of a language because
if you don't have that relationship
compliance and audit can be
horrible but if you can find people that
you start
having more of a let's understand each
other's vernacular and where we're
coming from
it goes a lot easier it is a lot of work
like the
the way a lawyer type thinks is very
different from the data scientist
very different but the the constant
communication
and camaraderie is is useful in the long
term
agree being now in a in a data
governance role it's just
it's just painful they they talk assets
and
and we talk data objects and they're
like what but yeah
once you bring them along it's it's
really pleasant
it also builds the um confidence in
what you're doing if if they feel like
they can see transparency and
and ask you questions about feeling
stupid yes
and i've noticed that uh in a room with
more than three people they will not
speak
i don't know if there's a ratio to
courage courageousness or something but
it's definitely interesting i
i think most people are scared of
looking stupid and
like the the title data scientist is
scary to most people
so unless you can
destroy that bridge of that wall
people aren't gonna talk to you
i'm balancing them forget that i was
just gonna say uh
imbalancing uh accuracy versus
explainability
depending on the methodology you choose
you know sometimes we may have to take a
hit
uh in accuracy because we can produce
something that shows
this is why it came up it followed this
path you know like
we use a tree model over something else
because i can give you a visual to say
this is why
the computer did this in this way versus
something that's not i can't give them a
handout or a powerpoint to explain the
work
you just have to trust me yeah
definitely
and sorry alan i realized that was your
question i just couldn't see your name
on where i'm keeping track of
all the questions so if you want to
provide any other context
or feedback on that question feel free
to jump in too
um yeah i think i was trying to think if
there was anything
that i wanted to add there i think um so
our environment has been has been
changing such that
there is more room and more opportunity
for these kinds of things but the
industry and in particular the folks who
drive
the quality system and change control at
that broad organizational level
um it's pretty hard to bring in to bring
in new things and have confidence and
i've been lucky enough for a few years
to be focused mostly in an area that
didn't need to be compliant
after having come from a space where i
had to be super compliant all the time
and i was like oh great freedom and now
we're pivoting back and becoming a
divisionally oriented function that is
probably going to have to figure out
some of these things again
um and so um so that's an interesting
place to be thinking about
where we have enjoyed being really
nimble and flexible in terms of
architecture and infrastructure and how
we approach things
we need to start wrapping some process
around it
again and so so it's just on my mind a
lot about how do we
how do we retain a lot of that
flexibility and i think the power that
comes with it
while being able to demonstrate that um
you know our environment does what it
what we think it does
that we could demonstrate that if need
be and it's going to be a negotiation
that we'll have to figure out but
it's um it's encouraging to hear that
folks have been successful
in those in those efforts even though
i know we'll have lots of details that
that are going to be kind of up in the
air for us for a little while
thanks thank you
i'm trying to uh scroll through to see
if there's any
questions that i miss so far um
hi i'm colin i i have a question i'm
just going to jump in here
perfect
i'm just i'm curious if you could speak
to how you think about
the different data
analytic projects that you tackle and
how it ties to business value
and i say that because i find often like
i can go off on side tracks of what i
think is
pretty interesting and kind of go down
rapid holes but then i have to step back
and
be like is this actually creating any
business value
um so i i just like to get your opinion
on that like how
how do you how do you think about this
the the project that you're tackling and
how it relates to
creating business value
so um it's really easy to go down those
rabbit holes
i've found works best for me and and
my team members that i've had do things
is make sure that you are
constantly working with business so that
you're not going to
down far down a rabbit hole that they're
like i don't care about that
it doesn't affect me at all where if i i
can get the business
partners feeling like it's their project
and they're right beside you like
helping through it
that that decreases the rabbit holes
it's still easy
but um i think we all have a tendency to
be like well that's an
interesting problem let's go look at it
but if you have that
consistent relationship with the
business person where you are
are truly working together and it's not
just
okay data scientist go do your thing and
then come back when you're done
that's when i think the rabbit hole
problem gets bad
and there's a tendency for i think both
sides be like well i'm busy
in the business so you just come back to
me later
and and that as the data scientist i
think you just cannot
you can't go for that like i require if
i'm doing work with you or for you
you have to be my partner otherwise
it's not going to succeed
i don't know if that helps you
but i i have noticed people don't spend
enough time creating that relationship
and enforcing that relationship what was
that sorry
i said that no that makes total sense
um yeah i've definitely had experience
of putting in you know hours and hours
on analysis and then
you know the business is like cool but i
don't know if they're using it or
um you know what exactly is happening
with it so
it's hard to say if that was even
worthwhile yeah
i've seen that go ahead sorry maybe i
can jump in sorry sorry to interrupt you
um and what you said before about the
talking with the people in compliance
uh i think was really relevant here also
because i think it's uh oftentimes this
communications issue
and one thing that i found is that
people will ask
how to do something and um i will show
them and maybe i'll spend half an hour
or even more
uh doing literally word for word what
they asked for and then
i would give them this beautiful result
i'd be so proud of myself that we came
up with this beautiful solution and
they'll be like
no that's not that's not what it was and
i'm like that's
that's literally word for what you asked
for and they'll be like yeah but no what
i mean was this and then
i realized that i didn't really get what
they really really wanted so
i think oftentimes in that relevance uh
what is it really useful is it really
can help the business is really asking
them
what like what do you really want to do
like why do you need this number what is
really the goal
and then you maybe can better help them
really understand okay like
what are we gonna do to have the really
maximum roi and that's something else
that i really talk to my
my students about what is what is the
minimal thing that's the easiest
smallest thing you can do
and have the greatest impact on your
work and on your life and
make things easier and then focus on
that like the the 80 20 rule basically
and then
they kind of started seeing things about
in in kind of a different way like am i
really doing something that's valuable
is it really something that's gonna have
a huge roi and then they're a little
more convinced to go about that but
that's a lot of communication i find
yeah that i think that's a common theme
that keeps coming up too is
communication with
business like understanding how to
communicate so that
it's relevant to them and that
i find that at least for me the
objective is to make them feel
ownership if i can get that ownership
where it's like their baby and they
care about the success or failure that's
the key
they're like cool it's your idea then
we're good
that's a great point i feel like that
came up on a few of the past
conversations as well like how do you
kind of make sure that you're working
closely enough with the business so that
they feel that it's
it's their project too
yeah if i follow up on that what does
that look like
tactically working with the business
yeah like you know communicating getting
them on board oh man
i spent so much time um
so for this current position i actually
created a
whole vision which then i had to go
evangelize and then
and yeah like i had to get top level
support
where it was the executives all the
executives were like yes we agree
and so i said okay if these are the
projects you need
who is responsible like who is my point
person
that has the flexibility to take the
time to be with me
you have to tell them that like this is
important not just to me but to you as
the boss and the executive
leadership and then it's been a lot of
one-on-one conversations but
i could try to make it not just
about the data science part i think a
lot of the communication to build that
relationship to get the ownership is
really understanding
what are the real underlying business
problems because a lot of people will be
like
they think problem a is their problem
but it's not and only during a lot of
conversation and really
understanding and feeling their pain do
you understand what the real problem is
and that is what you got to kind of suss
out
it makes the relationship good like
people feel heard
if you actually are understanding the
real problem
does that kind of answer your question
wrong
thumbs up one last share before i need
to drop off the way
the way i open operationalize this was
during the engagement process we're
doing elicitation and and i would ask
the the leaders that were asking for the
work
for a co-pilot and this person was going
to share
and learn and you know which they share
business we share a tech
and eventually they take over the
analytics so it can keep surviving
so if they didn't up front coming to a
co-pilot to do the switch when the
project was almost done
that told me that they were really not
that interested they're just kicking
tires
and we really never really engage with
them
something that i've also found that
helps build the relationships and helps
the
business take ownership is when you're
presenting
have them do it
that really makes people feel ownership
and proud and then they
they care particularly if they're
presenting like and then they feel cool
which is great
so
tori i see rick has a follow-up question
to what you just shared and
rick do you want to jump in and share
that
sure uh i put in the in the chat the
question was when you mentioned this
thing about the
getting them to come up with the real
problem uh which
i i'm also kind of doing that the
question was
do you document that somehow like do you
have um
like a protocol where we state where the
problem is
and then we take the steps and then
there's kind of a
uh that we can see the progression of
how we went from the original problem to
the so-called real problem which is
interesting in itself to understand
how that process worked and you can show
people how that worked and then also the
other one is
it kind of covers covers yourself
because you can kind of show
whoever like well that like it's on
paper like that that's what we said we
were gonna do
and we did it so that people don't come
back afterwards and say it wasn't
did you have some kind of a strategy for
doing that so
in the past because where i am now it's
so new i've
not been as good at documenting that
whole process flow
previously um yes i like
and for each project or working with
somebody we'd start out with saying
this is the objective where we're going
and we basically have
minutes and notes that would just tack
on
not that fancy just just like just done
note meetings
like the notes from the meeting it
wasn't basically like a standard
like sometimes um there's more of a
structured
uh document you know it's in some
protocols like if i'm going to do an
experiment
there's a clear this is the input this
is what the what the reagent was this is
the incubation like this all the little
pieces inside
and then you have the results and then
you can make a clear direction between
the results and the conditions of the
experiment
and so i kind of think of something like
that for um instead of just like this
kind of unstructured media notes
which um leave a lot to subjective
people's writing
with what they want and also
interpretation more of like a clear
like um okay this is the goal project
this is the variables these are the data
sets
this is the main question and then this
is what each of the variables mean these
are the problems with each of the
variables these are the techniques that
are recommended the pros and the cons
and then a little bit more of a cleared
outline in that way do you think that's
worthwhile
yes so by the point at um you're
actually producing
some output yes but like to get to that
output
there's so much iteration beforehand
that a lot of the
findings they're documented but not as
strictly as by final outputs
like here are the iterations this is
what we've tried this is why we didn't
use this variable
sorry i thought you were thinking more
of in the discussions of trying to suss
out what the real problem is
i've found that's a lot messier at least
for me i wish i could come
up with a stricter but i think i'm
i'm not as clear-cut as i probably
should be in that part
it gets easier i think once you start
swapping out variables and being like oh
no this didn't work let's document it if
that kind of makes sense
yeah okay clearly i should work on that
a bit
i know we're getting to the top of the
hour here and a few people have to jump
off but happy to stay on for any other
questions that we haven't had a chance
to answer yet i know there's one
question from earlier that
actually kind of touches on a few of the
earlier points around building the
community
and training but touches upon
like why now like why
is your team starting to make this
change whether it's from sas to excel
and moving over to r and python like
what has been
the key driver there for me
yeah for you can i also champion for
you know them for about one minute so i
actually from uh
you know the understanding table and the
last few years i've been teaching
hour for you know the students and i
think
the main challenge to how to get
students on board
and i also teach you know tableau and i
think
in comparison i think r is more
user-friendly
and then tableau is like you know a
different excel so for me
and you know still most most students
prefer to use tableau because you know
they thought you know maybe it's more
popular i might
i tell them you know the truth is that
you know fewer are passed under more
jobs available
i think you know i think the tablet
probably did
something which you know which could
help them grow
you know their popularity you know
in the business community and also in
you know in academia so primarily i
think
they introduced um you know university
ambassadors
to university students so let's say if
you are good at using tableau if you are
proficient
maybe you know they will give you a
title because this student is a tableau
ambassador
and then the center and portfolio to you
know the company and
they apply to their ambassadors and then
they can organize you know i mean meet
ups or even
i mean let's say our has been such a
great language in which i benefit
personally and professionally
uh i would say you know maybe in the
future if you can
organize more data analytics you know
competitions for
students are probably meet ups uh
probably you know
you know this kind of recognitions so i
mean the next generation student they
could benefit from the skills otherwise
then
the
graduates they only have excel spss
which you know
i mean sps probably nobody wants to use
it if you know
from a company but majority professors
still teach
spss i i understand maybe a few years
ago when i started teaching art
i had maybe less than five students who
picked up
the our programming language and at the
end of the semester he told me that you
know he was working for a banking
company and he said you know he was
using sentiment analysis to analyze
you know customers you know customer
complaints
my first time ever and he's a he has a
bad
you know engineering background so
majority of students do not have at you
know background to understand how art
works
yes thank you that's a good point jimmy
is
tori is that something that um waffed
bank
does for internships or like maybe data
competitions i know
in like the sports analytics meetup we
talked a little bit about like the big
data bowl
and that's how they find a lot of people
for new positions
so um we are in our absolute infancy so
now
previously one of the things that i
found useful
not where i am but um my prior bank
we did a lot with the local university
which was awesome like it started
building
a relationship between like the data
scientists at
the bank and the university and it
helped drive actually what the
university was
teaching and found some hires there that
was awesome
but the issue with
banking is so many of the universities
are like can we get an actual data set
because real data versus the stuff we
have is
they're not comparable right real data
is so much messier and harder than the
lovely like iris data set
and so people come out of college and
they don't actually know how to
how to really deal with problems in the
data set
so i i've yet to figure out how to get
something like that going i i know there
are a few banks that have been able to
create get get their compliance okay to
let people have some competitions with
their data which i think would be
awesome
i have not yet figured out how to do
that
i don't think i see any other questions
in the chat but one other question that
i i'd love to ask tori is
do you have any advice for people who
are on or
maybe aspiring data science leaders for
getting into leadership roles
into a leadership role i think it has to
do with
partnerships with the businesses and
communication
i've noticed the people that are able to
speak the language of the business
people are the ones that do the best
um i know it's fun to talk about the
statistics and
the fun modeling that you go into but
that does not generally
make an executive go wow they care about
the dollars
and if you're able to relate things back
to how it affects the business and the
bottom line and speak
that language those are the ones those
are the people that generally get
picked to start presenting and to
talking with
other leaders because they can actually
communicate and understand what you're
saying
so there's it's it's a lot of work to
understand the business and to be able
to
speak both like mathy nerd
and business but that's really the key
thank you tori yeah it seems like so
much of it really goes back to
the communication piece yeah
well i know we're a little bit over on
our original uh
time and i don't see any other questions
i just want to say thank you so much
tori for sharing your insights and your
experience
and thank you all for joining as well
um tori quick question if people want to
get in contact with you what's the best
way
um probably my gmail
here i'll type it you can try linkedin
i'm just not good in social media
i will check it eventually there we go
awesome thank you tori and thank you so
much everyone for joining hopefully
we'll see you next week
same time can i ask a quick question for
people are still here
something i was thinking about that has
been driving me crazy
just about data science is like
i wish there were i'm
frustrated that there is a lack of a
professional certification organization
so this runs into a couple different
things like
one of the issues i see where data
science fails
is because there is bad analysis like
people
aren't actually able to produce
something because they don't have the
basic skills that they need but then
people that want to actually understand
that they have the skills and can tout
it have a harder time of doing that
and i was like man the these
societies exist for like every other
profession
so you've got accountants becoming cpas
you have financial analysts
like the good ones or cfas sorry i'm
saying all
acronyms right unchartered financial
analysts lawyers
they have the bar everybody in
all these other professions have some
kind of professional organization but we
don't as data scientists
and so like a lot of people trying to
become a data scientist they don't have
an understanding of what the minimum
requirements are
which i think would be useful for them
i'm curious if this is a sentiment that
other people have or
i'm just going crazy i'm like maybe
jj can fix this one rachel
yo um i mean
one one of the things that all those
professions or most of them have in
common is they're
they're protected names so you can't
call yourself
a doctor you can't call yourself a
lawyer or an accountant unless you have
that and those are names that are
regulated and protected so
if you call yourself a doctor and you
don't have that then then you're screwed
and so
um in one sense i don't think data
scientists
would be ever a protected name because
scientists know right i'm a biologist
that's true
but you know because i have i have a
doctor title but a lot of people that
don't have a doctor title called
themselves the biologist and
i disagree with that but i can't i can't
um say
say anything to them um and i think
science as a
in general is not really a protected um
a protected name
that people can have uh but i also
wanted to mention um
based on that there is this um uh do you
know the dhamma
uh the data management um organization
i'm going to send you i'll put in the in
the chat so this is the only one that i
ever found
because i got a task to do a data
management um
um a proposal and that i
disappeared into the ether so i don't
know what happened with it but because
of that i did a lot of research into
these guys and this is the only one
that and they're certified their schools
that they that they pan out and
it seems to be the only for me was the
only one maybe other people in the class
in the group no other ones that seem to
be the only quasi
widely recognized certification in the
field although
every everybody in the brother's got a
different certification program
um and there are schools that they will
will certify you can do the
certification for us
and i have seen people ask for it so as
data management becomes more popular
this is this is being asked for on um
job job
profiles but it's not specific for
actually doing data science itself but
it's something related
okay the one thing that has been
frustrating for me is
going through i feel like a lot of
people will take one course and like
on corsair and they're like i'm a data
scientist i'm like hold up
there are like some fundamentals you
need to understand
like key hacking is a problem do you
actually under
basic understand basic statistics
anyway i i get really frustrated as well
i'm sure you're sent to me
okay i'll check that out thank you
it's a great point though tori
especially as people talk about
reproducibility crisis and all that that
there is the fact that there is no real
certification
there yeah yeah go ahead go oh go ahead
now i was going to ask actually you were
talking
this is sort of the technical skills you
know do they have the stats and that
the understanding the certification
around that but you were talking earlier
about the business
communication or business understanding
and communication just wondering how do
you
i don't know is that a hiring thing like
what is that how do you
make sure you get people that not only
do they know how to do the
the data science piece but they have the
business piece as well
when i'm hiring well or
just if you're inherited you're building
a team but if you have yeah
already when i've when i've inherited
teams
it becomes pretty clear who is
interested in
owning and really thinking and
unfortunately a lot of people don't like
to think
they generally leave if the expectations
are
are high and and their peers don't feel
like they're
pursuing it are you asking if how do i
make sure a new hire
has those softer skills well
i guess what i'm wondering is if that's
a critical component of the success of
the team
how do you sure that the team has those
skills
hiring seems to be an obvious place but
if you already have a team
i guess what you're doing is you're
setting expectations and they weed
themselves out
that that does work actually um for the
statistics and understanding what
they're doing i feel like that is an
absolute fundamental if you can't talk
to somebody that's a different problem
but if you're making just bad analysis
it's going to destroy the team
the credibility is gone um
my previous team there was a range of
who liked to do what and because the
the technical skills were all solid not
everybody wants to talk
to the business so the people that
actually were good at it
could take that role
and and in hiring every time we're up to
get a new person like the team would
actually get together being like
what qualities are we lacking as a team
so what do we need to really focus on to
make sure this person is adding that
value to our team
i don't think everybody is the same i
think you have like you rely on each
other that's when it
become powerful
so have you ever seen
like a project manager taking that kind
of role like the communication with
the business or is it usually someone
from the team that wants to
do that my experience with project
managers
is not awesome we've had i've had one
that i really liked
because and i'm sure there are some
great ones like
it's not that big but we would just take
on project management ourselves
because generally the project managers
we had
would turn more into task managers and
not understand
really the intricacies like i think
not that long ago somebody brought up
their frustration with
scrum and like the
whole now we're doing stand-up meetings
and it's
it doesn't seem to be working for data
science and i
i get that completely because data
science and building a
software product are so different but
everybody assumes it's the same
and they like it feels to me like
project management
is generally more on a this is the
dedicated timeline and you're going to
hit that
and that's not really data science so
i've not found project managers that
useful
it the one exception is they often will
know
more people initially
at a company so they can help connect
you with the person but
for communication can i can i ask on the
on the product managers and the scrum
do you think because this was a big
conversation for a while that
data science cannot be done in an agile
way
and it just because like would you say
it just doesn't work that way but
there's a there's a lot of people who
argue that actually yeah it can
work in that way and that um also when
it comes back to this topic that we
mentioned before i mean i'm i'm
i'm on the fence it doesn't matter
either way but uh some like what we
mentioned before
this like reiteration and communication
coming back and back
and actually that would fit well with
with this uh these kind of sprints and
then
having a clear result and then checking
in are we going the right direction and
then
so some people argue that actually it
does work quite well
i think it can work well i think people
try to shove data science
into how they do um
how they create a software
product and it's it's that of something
into the box it doesn't work
like data science if we not aren't
actually
agile if we're not failing fast and
making sure what we're doing still makes
sense will fail
and what frustrates me is i'm like hold
on the idea
of agility isn't scrum
and i it seems like people like cross
those wires and like
yeah you want to fail fast let's make
sure we're doing things that are
reasonable and not like going down a
rabbit hole and not talking to somebody
for a month
yeah but the timeline thing can be
tricky and i'm not
i'm not sure about all that either i i
still kind of prefer kanban boards to uh
the currents from i don't know i'm on
the fence too
rob b i see you unmuted yourself did you
have a final question
yeah uh and thanks again for doing this
tori um there's there's
so there's business skills um and then i
guess one
one level deeper is there's
industry level skills um like so you
know understanding like you're a data
scientist at a
financial services company you
understand finance is is that on the
sort of critical path for a hire on your
team or in your organization
no um
so when i look at hires i care if they
can think logically
i do not care if they even have
programming
or if they understand the industry i
care about the way they think because
i'm like
okay if if you think logically like
hopefully they have programming most
people now that
are applying have programming but i can
teach
banking i cannot teach logic
like if you don't think that way that's
not gonna work but banking i can teach
discount cash flow why bankers do things
the way they are that's
simple compared to what i expect from
a budding data scientist
so no like my last team i don't think
there was one person i hired internally
everybody else had
um like it came from oceanography
physics math and none of them were
banking
and i actually found that really helpful
because people see
problems differently when they come from
different industries
it's more of how do you tackle a problem
when you interview how do you test for
that skill
can they think logically um i do
actually use
tests so like we do have the regular
talking through people but um
so i i usually give a couple different
tests one is a
take home like you have x amount of
hours and here's some data
do something with it give me a report
and it's really open-ended
i found so there's not like uh
wait like there's so many ways you can
solve it correctly the
wrong answers are just blatant
it's just obvious the other thing that i
i don't know how to we've been doing it
over online and it's weird to do it
online but
it's nice to have somebody actually come
in and try to do something live without
internet
be like okay here's a computer if you
want um
here is your task you have to solve go
for it
and i don't really care if they solve it
i want to see how they go about it
so i had one guy that could not for the
life of him remember the package i think
he chose to use python
it was like i don't care what
programming language you do you have
this task and he could not remember how
to
run a regression so on pen and paper
he did the entire he like
figured it all out and then used his own
algorithm and implemented it and i was
like
he was one of the best hires i've ever
hired like it was
it was beautiful anyway it's
i try to pinpoint what are the skills
and the thinking
that i want to see can you demonstrate
that or
because what i really want to avoid is
the people that will be like i'm going
to throw
all this data and use like a combo
convolutional neural network to solve
something that really could be done with
regular expressions because i've seen
this
like and that's what i don't want which
is
it's really obvious with some simple
tasks
anyway that's great do you ever ask them
because you touched on it before
you know asking them to explain it to
someone what they just did
and if you then get people talking about
here's the model
and you know that piece as opposed to
the value do you test
that as well yeah yeah when um
played around with a couple things when
somebody is doing like a live
coding or a live it's more of a can you
explain your thought process as you're
going through this
which is really enlightening
i find it useful to see what type of
questions people ask or if
like how how much will they persist
how much understanding are they trying
to dig
which is that sounds subjective but it
is it becomes very apparent
going off of robert's question though
and
do you do you find a lot of hires that
do think logically but really only when
it comes to the data science aspect
and in the process of teaching them the
banking and the business side
um i guess a lot of these questions
around what is the value of these things
connecting with the business partners i
think i was thinking what robert was
is you know it might be helpful to find
people who already have that sense of
why this is valuable to the business and
it sounds like you're
you're more confident in your ability to
just train them to do that and you want
them to have those core skills instead
um what is my question here uh what you
know what does training them on the
business
look like to you um
so i always force people to actually
have serious partnerships but i think i
understand your question because i've
had a few employees where
they get so excited about the modeling
that they forget that actually we have
to like
make value or there is no reason that we
exist
we're just becoming an expense
so i've had to have those conversations
before i know this is exciting but there
is a balance
between figuring out a really cool way
of doing this
and giving real value without taking too
much time
those are those are conversations and
depending on the person
that there are just people that would
love to be in academia
but are not
so some of the phd
phds i have had a more of that with
and i think that's just like you've been
in school forever that is what you do
so
but oh you know what i had one other
thought because we're still talking um
getting people to present their results
is useful
but i've had to coach multiple people
being like okay remember who's in the
audience you're talking to the ceo is he
going to care about this
no he cares about his financials
showing this this and this so how can
you relate this back
instead of spoon feeding it though like
you got to get them to actually
understand how to do that
which takes time
so i do have a meeting in like five
minutes but
i have to say i'm waiting to be like an
appropriate amount to see if someone
else jumped in
but thank you so much tori and thank you
thank you guys this is fun
this is a great great session i hope to
see you next week too
you